alexander und die angehörigen seiner
dienststelle sind stolz unter dem neuen
organisationsbereich selber und
informationsraum sichern die gemeinsam
die handlungsfähigkeit der bundeswehr
hacker haben so keine chance mehr
mit schlecht bestellt sein schöner
erklärte nur leider nicht besonders
realistisch das geht doch besser alle
kinder und seine anderen dicken hacker
kumpel ist sind wahnsinnig stolz auf
ihre festanstellung beim bund wird
können sie vielleicht bald wieder bei
mama ausziehen dann sagen sie kämpfen
gegen diesen panzerknacker aus micky
maus weil wir nicht zugeben wollen dass
es gegen den russen und bieten den
chinesen geht denn das wäre voll
rassistischer und eins ist sicher weil
ihre arbeit im hacker kommando lernen
alexander und co der radiert keine
frauen gelten
aber das ist gelungen das cyber kommando
endlich krieg in sitzen
ja
klingt schön